i wanted to get to ruchi because uh you
know you
part of his his come up on ruchi i think
the first record i heard of his was the
lean like a cholo [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
damn he was just getting up on him yeah
yeah yeah yeah that was crazy dallas
played me that oh yeah yeah that was
crazy
and uh i was like oh this [ __ ] is yeah
tight like someone remixed [ __ ] yeah
yeah that record you know
but uh how did you how did you meet
ruchi and like kind of what's your
involvement with roruchi because
obviously he's on youtube
um daddy is my big homie like
big taco my big homie he raised me in
the streets from when i was like
13. you know what i'm saying until
[ __ ] he went to jail you know what i
mean so now he's in mexico right yeah he
in mexico now he got deported
so so i've known ruchi and angel since
they was little babies
we used to babysit them you know i mean
make sure they don't drive and
go running in the um driveway and [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so
i've been knowing him as a but then he
kind of moved away for like
four or five years and when he came back
i think uh sean mack brought him in i
was my little brother rest in peace you
know what i'm saying
he brought him in the studio one day i'm
like i got [ __ ] in here man come on
bro taco finish
tripping y'all got him hanging with us
and like nah
he went in there and and dropped the
verse and i was like damn
oh [ __ ] i'm ruchi [ __ ] ain't you feel
me i'm like okay
and then ever since that one verse he
just been boom boom boom boom
grinding and then um i feel like when
the homie sean died he um
he just just that [ __ ] just for the
battery
with me when he passed it just had me
like
i ain't gonna say like under a rock but
i had no motivation right right
to do nothing you think it affected him
the other way infected him
if it affected him like different he
just the soul of him just came out and
he was like both of them rapping on
songs
wow so he had the aggression the the
the um the the word play
and everything all in the song
everything that shawn had and he just
added
fuel to the flame you know what i'm
saying he and it's just a work ethic
got him to where he i'm staying where he
had now